bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
france 24 c'est un des défis du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro réconcilier
les mémoires singulière de la guerre
d'algérie et pour relever ce défi il a
fait appel à vous benjamin stora
historien
incontournable autour auteur d'une
bibliographie impressionnante sur la
question et plus largement sur la
période coloniale vous avez conseillé
jacques chirac ou françois hollande mais
c'est avec emmanuel macron que la
question de la mémoire du conflit s'est
imposé comme jamais auparavant né à
constantine à l'aube des années 50 un
article du quotidien le monde vous
présentez comme les deux rives de la
mémoire franco algérienne vous êtes
l'auteur d'un rapport désormais
communément appelé rapport stores a
publié chez albin michel sous le titre
france algérie les passions douloureuse
un rapport qui préconise un certain
nombre d'actions pour réconcilier les
mémoires alors des mémoires singulière
des douleurs multiples vous avez eu
cette formule une histoire en proie aux
saignements des mémoires blessées c'est
tout ça qui fait que le chemin est long
et tortueux vers l'apaisement oui tout à
fait vous avez raison de citer cette
phrase qui est dans mon rapport des
saignements de mémoire ce qui veut dire
que ça ne s'est pas christelle
cicatriser pardon c'est à dire si la
mémoire continuer à saigner c'est que
les blessures n'arrive pas à se refermer
fondamentalement pour des tas de raisons
que j'ai exposé dans ce rapport mais
aussi dans d'autres ouvrages comme la
gangrène et l'oubli que j'ai sorti en
1991 il ya déjà trente ans les raisons
sont multiples d'abord parce que la
présence coloniale française en algérie
a duré cent trente deux ans est colossal
il n'y a pas d'équivalent avec une
colonie de peuplement considérable bien
évidemment il n'y a pas d'équivalent
dans toute l'histoire de l'empiré
colonial et puis la guerre elle-même la
séparation a duré près de huit ans une
guerre qu elle une cohérence sanglante
très compliqué ce qui fait que
différents groupes porteurs de cette
mémoire à quelques mois qu'ils
appartiennent c'est à dire les soldats
un million et demi de jeunes français
sont partis en algérie bien sûr les
algériens bien sûr les immigrés
algériens en france bien sûr les harkis
et bien sûr les européens d'algérie ce
qu'on a appelé les pieds-noirs et bien
tous ces groupes porteurs de cette
mémoire douloureuse dans le fond avait
le sentiment et on le anti vent toujours
d'être incompris pas écouté
avec peu d'initiatives qui ont été peu
d'écouté peu d'attention qui leur ont
été portés ce qui fait que 60 ans après
ben on est toujours dans une situation
très difficile alors on va parler
brièvement de la date du 19 mars 1962
alors vous avez expliqué dans une
interview que j'ai vu sur internet que
on avait tendance à résumer la guerre
d'algérie sur quelques dates de la fin
du conflit de l'année 62 notamment il ya
cette date du 18 19 mars 19 mars c'est
la mise en oeuvre du cessez-le-feu mais
c'est une date qui est contesté par un
certain nombre de personnes notamment
des rapatriés d'algérie alors cette date
est ce qu'elle mérite d'être commémorée
bah oui parce que
c'est c'est pour le 19 mars 62 c'est
très important pour les appeler c'est à
dire pour ceux pour les hommes du
contingent qui était en algérie avec
quatre cent mille hommes en algérie et
pour eux c'était là qui c'était la fin
la fin de la guerre donc la possibilité
de revenir aux métropoles donc c'est
très important pour les appelés du
contingent mais vous avez raison de le
signaler que ce soit du côté français ou
du côté algérien c'est une date contre
qui a été contesté contesté bien sûr par
les européens d'algérie puisqu'il ya eu
la fusillade fameuse classique terrible
tragédie de la rue d'isly du 26 mars 62
qui a été reconnu d'ailleurs par le
président de la république mais aussi
aux l'oubli on le sait beaucoup mois
date qui a été contesté par les
algériens eux-mêmes qui était en conflit
avec la france et qui voyaient d'un
mauvais oeil cette date comme un mauvais
compromis en fait fondamentalement ce
qui fait qu en algérie cette date n'a
pas été commémorée pendant très
longtemps c'est seulement depuis
quelques années maintenant on parle du
jour de la victoire que la possibilité
d'une commémoration mais d'un côté comme
de l'autre on avait le sentiment qu'il
s'agissait d'une espèce de trêve fragile
précaire temporaire et qu'elle ne
signifiait pas véritablement la guerre
la fin de la guerre d'algérie c'est pour
ça que mise à part l'action très forte
des appelés du contingent à travers
leurs associations
c'est pour cela que donc cette date à
être toujours été véritablement
problématique d'autant plus que ce qui
avait été évoqué dans ces accords n'a
pas forcément été mises en oeuvre et une
autre date celle du 5 juillet il est une
date de bonheur de joie pour les
algériens mais en même temps une
tragédie pour beaucoup d'européens
essentiellement des français oui alors
on peut multiplier comme ça les dates de
fin de guerre parce qu'il faut signaler
quand même de la fin la guerre d'algérie
a été particulièrement tragique et cruel
c'est pour ça aussi qu'il ya autant de
dates en ont récemment on a parlé par
exemple de sharon le 8 février bien sûr
assassinat par exemple de mouloud
feraoun d'un grand écrivain gérer à et
ses compagnons qui ont été assassinés le
15 mars 1962 par l'ol mais bien sûr le
19 mars et le 5 juillet le 5 juillet où
le 3 juillet parce que la france
reconnaît officiellement l'indépendance
de l'algérie le le 3 juillet 1962 mais
pour les algériens la date du 5 juillet
beaucoup plus importante que ce que la
date d'arrivée de la france en algérie
du 5 juillet 1830 mais vous avez raison
de le souligner cette date à la de
plusieurs aspects à la fois d'
enthousiasme de joie venant d'algérie de
toutes les villes d'algérie
c'est à dire la possibilité du passage à
l'indépendance politique c'est très
important et puis à oran ou dans la
région d'oran une tragédie les
enlèvements d'européens plusieurs
centaines d'européens ont été enlevés et
assassinés donc ça reste bien sûr pour
les rapatriés d'algérie une date très
très difficile d'ailleurs qui a été
évoqué là aussi dans le un discours
récent du président de la république
alors suivant les recommandations de
votre rapport émet le maquereau a fait
un certain nombre de gestes forts comme
la reconnaissance de l'implication de
l'armée dans la mort du militant
communiste prend indépendance maurice
audin encore la station l'assassinât de
l'avocat ali boumendjel sur le chemin de
la réconciliation il n'est pas question
d'excuser parce que ça a été quelque
chose dont on a beaucoup parlé au moment
de la parution de votre rapport vous
savez quand j'ai fait ce rapport et
c'est mentionné à l'intérieur j'ai
évoqué la question des excuses jeudi des
excuses pourquoi pas c'est écrit noir
sur blanc mais devant un tel incendie
mémorielle depuis 160 ans est ce qu'un
seul discours suffire à apaiser cet
incendie gigantesque des mémoires c'est
ça mon problème or j'ai choisi de faire
ce qu'on a appelé la politique des
petits pas ses terres de la
multiplication des gestes symboliques et
donc de dessiner une sorte d'arc en ciel
mémorielle symbolique qui au fur et
mesure permettrait à différents groupes
porteurs de la mémoire de pouvoir
s'identifier et essayer de réparer les
choses vous avez dit bien sûr maurice
audin ali boumendjel bien entendu c'est
très important le 17 octobre 1961 pour
la première fois un président de la
république est venu sur recueillir à la
mémoire de travailleur algérien
assassiné ça ne s'était jamais fait
sharon bien entendu ça c'est très
important l'ouverture des archives qui a
été disons une ouverture de cas avec
quinze ans d'avancé par rapport à ce qui
était prévu il yad'autres d'autres
choses qui ont été faites par exemple il
ya eu tout un énorme colloque qui s'est
tenu à la bibliothèque nationale de
france à l'institut du monde arabe où
près d'une trentaine d'universitaires
ont évoqué la figure des personnalités
qui étaient anti colonialiste donc c'est
des choses qu'on ne perçoit mal parce
qu'on a le sentiment surtout dans la
jeunesse française que dans le fond
pendant cette période il y avait une
sorte de bloc je veux dire homogène pro
coloniale ce qui est pas vrai il ya eu
des gens qui se sont élevées contre le
système colonial les grandes figures de
jean paul sartre simone de beauvoir bien
sûr denrées à l'aide d'andré land use
andré breton enfin je veux pas citer ici
toutes les grandes figures de
l'intelligentia françaises qui ont
refusé de cette histoire est peinte dans
mon rapport j'avais cette préconisation
j'avais évoqué disons cette possibilité
bien sûr et puis j'avais évoqué aussi la
possibilité d'une stèle en hommage de
l'émir abdelkader dans la ville
d'amboise où il avait été enfermé après
sa reddition et cette dalle qui a été
édifié malheureusement a été vandalisé
alors que émirats l'émir abdelkader
était un personnage extraordinaire
personnage de tolérance d'humanisme qui
a combattu la france bien sûr mais aussi
un personnage passerelle mais aussi un
personnage qui voulait conciliez vous
revient à cette fameuse conciliation
réconciliation et bien l'orient et
l'occident notamment par exemple en
sauvant les chrétiens à damas en 1867 un
personnage aussi très intéressant parce
que tu as un personnage religieux qui
voulaient concilier la foi et la raison
donc il ya toute une série de 2 décrit
philosophique de l'émir et ceux qui ont
vandalisé disons cette stèle dans le
fond on ignorait tout de cette histoire
c'est l'ignorance disons qu'ils essaient
de triompher par rapport à une
réconciliation possible
alors justement on a vu que emmanuel
macron a fait un certain nombre de
gestes plus que ses prédécesseurs mais
on n'a pas forcément le sentiment que le
niveau d' apaisement entre la france et
l'algérie soit supérieur à celui qu'il a
été notamment pendant les années
hollande comment vous expliquez ça alors
tout d'abord il faut dire qu'en l'espace
d'un an il y à une nombre de gestes qui
a été accompli est supérieur à tout ce
qui a été fait pendant 60 ans quand même
signalé çà je veux dire avant de marquer
les insuffisances nouvel effet les
problèmes le ce qu'il reste à accomplir
et c'est ça n'avait jamais été fait tous
ces gestes de caractère symbolique
s'adressant à la fois aux harkis
s'adressant au pied noir s'adressant aux
immigrés algériens en france et c'est à
un arc encore une fois c'est un bruit
considérable la moitié de mes
préconisations été réalisés jamais
lorsque j'ai déposé ce rapport en
janvier 2021 je pensais qu'il y aurait
autant de réalisations de préconisations
il ya aussi par exemple le fait de
donner des bourses de recherche son
appel les bourses andré mandouze à des
chercheurs algériens des jeunes
chercheurs algériens mais en même temps
vous avez raison de souligner que
malgré tous ces gestes accomplis il ya
eu des tensions encore toujours même si
elles sont moins vives que ce qu'on a
connu à quelques mois bien entendu mais
effectivement c'est très difficile vous
savez en l'espace de d'une année
seulement de pouvoir combler le retard
accumulé de 60 années 60 années imaginez
que par exemple
aucun président de la république se
réclamant de la gauche n'avait déposé
deux gerbes à la mémoire et en hommage
au militant communiste de charonne c'est
donc j'avais été faire des choses je
n'avais jamais arrêté fait accompli et
mais ça reste il reste encore beaucoup
de choses à accomplir par exemple les
essais nucléaires la réparation des
populations civiles ont été touchées il
ya bien sûr l'entretien des cimetières
en algérie c'est des questions
extrêmement intéressante et importante
pour faire le travail de deuil etc etc
alors on n'a plus beaucoup de temps
j'avais une dernière question à vous
poser dans une interview vous avez
expliqué j'étais celui qui écrivait
l'histoire je veux faire d'histoires à
ce que vous avez le sentiment d'y être
parvenu ou de commencer et parvenir à je
n'ai pas cette prétention de faire
l'histoire il ya toujours ce vieux rêve
de des historiens engagé qui marquent
l'histoire cette liste et je m'inscrirai
volontiers dans cette vie dans cette
longue liste d'historiens de michel et à
pierre vidal naquet qui ont joué un rôle
très important car faire de l'histoire
c'est aussi quelque part faire de la
politique il faut pas se le cacher bien
entendu l'histoire est une discipline
très politique parce qu'elle ne vise pas
simplement à nous enfermer dans le passé
mais à tracer des pistes ils ont de
compréhension du présent et de l'avenir
donc oui je pense que ce rapport marque
loi la preuve c'est que nous sommes ici
pour en discuter plus d'un an après plus
d'un an après alors que tant et tant de
rapports ont été faits dont on ne parle
plus jamais donc ça veut dire que c'est
un rapport qui est un marqueur dans
l'histoire des relations franco
algériennes merci beaucoup benjamin
stora malheureusement c'est déjà la fin
de cette émission j'avais beaucoup
d'autres questions à vous poser
l'information continue sur france 24 à
très bientôt
[Musique]